[Music]
they know my work is based on the polls
don't they how do Americans want the
Senate to evaluate Donald Trump's
nominee for the Supreme Court in two
recent polls bare majority said that
they wanted Trump to choose a nominee
based on his or her qualifications
around four inten said that he should
consider the person's views on
controversial issues like abortion gun
control or immigration how should
senators judge a nominee polls make
clear that Americans want the Senate to
play an active role in the confirmation
process Americans want senators to ask
nominees their views on controversial
issues and Americans want the nominee to
state their views publicly but when
people are asked whether a nominee
should be required to state his or her
views Americans are opposed additionally
only small numbers in the range of 15 to
20 percent say it is acceptable for
senators to base their vote solely on a
nominees position on an issue such as
abortion or immigration the polls show
that Americans reject single issue a
litmus test for the high court but they
want to know who the nominees are and
what they believe to learn more about my
take on the Supreme Court nomination
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you'd
like a AEI scholars to cover in 60
seconds
[Music]